so you might remember last year when a
drug company raised the price of its
drug by 5,000% the reaction particularly
when you read the papers today has been
quite critical of this move so why well
you know we needed to turn a profit on
the drug that's Martin shkreli the
former CEO of turing pharmaceuticals he
bought an old drug called daraprim which
treats life-threatening diseases in HIV
patients an overnight raised the price
from $13.50 a pill to 750 dollars that
caused outrage Hillary Clinton tweeted
about price gouging biotech stops
dropped into a bear market an even
Pharma the industry's lobby group in
Washington distanced itself from turing
but raising prices is actually pretty
common in the industry tick marks
januvia millions of Americans use it to
treat diabetes when Merck started
selling the pill in 2006 it cost about a
hundred and forty six dollars a month by
2011 it was two hundred and thirteen
dollars a month now 30 days worth of
januvia costs at least 370 dollars more
than twice what it did when Merck
started selling it adjust for inflation
and were still seeing a massive increase
Novartis raised the price of its cancer
drug Gleevec from 30 1930 dollars a year
in 2001 to about one hundred and
eighteen thousand dollars a year in 2015
and Pfizer raised prices on at least a
hundred and thirty three of its drugs
last year so why did drug prices keep
going up for one drug makers say R&D is
risky and expensive the industry spent
more than 50 billion dollars on R&D in
2014 and most drugs fail somewhere
between the test tube and the many
clinical trials the FDA requires before
a medicines okayed for sale to the
public for the drugs that do get
approved on average they have about 12
years of dominance before cheap generics
come on the market and create
competition since the US doesn't
regulate drug prices pharmaceutical
companies try to make as much profit as
they can before those generics come to
market in fact fives were made about a
billion dollars more from mid 2012 to
mid 2014 just because of price increases
on their drugs in the case of turing
shkreli was kicked out and in november
the company said it would cut the price
of the drug by as much 50% for some
hospitals but at a congressional hearing
in March one doctor who treats the
patients needing the drug said she was
still having too
getting it at an affordable price Turing
is an extreme example but the reality is
drug companies have been doing it for
years and aren't likely to change